القوتان
في مواجهه عنيفه مباشره بينهما منذ صباح
السبت
والى الان يبدو هنالك حشد
لبعض من الشات ولكن
المسلحتين او جيشين
بشكل اساسي في العاصمه في الخرطوم
ومع غلق المطار واغلب الجسور وقتال الشديد
في المناطق المحاديه
للمطار وكذلك المقر العسكريه والمقر
المختلفه لقوات الدعم السريع والجيش حول
الخرطوم وقتال شديد في دارفور
في سلنجي
والمناطق المركزيه في جنوب دارفور
اكثر من 180 شخصا من المدنيين جرحوا
خلال ايام الثلاثه الماضيه
واكثر من
اعداد كبيره من القتلى
والجرحى من ضمنهم
ثلاثه
زملاء عمله مع برنامج الغذاء العالمي
قتلوا بينما كانوا يقدمون الخدمات الشعب
السوداني في دارفور
القتال المستمر
وبشكل مستمر
ومن الصعب ان نعرف
موازنه القوى
وبدعم للشركاء من المنطقه بذلت جهودا
لاقناع عقاده الطرفين
لوقف اطلاق النار واتفاقي على
ايقاف انساني مؤقت
لتمكين رجالي والنساء والاطفال السودانيين
للذهاب الى الاماكن امنه
هو الحصول على مؤن من اجل افطار رمضان
يتناولونه ويشربونه هو لمن يرغب بالذهاب
الى المستشفى
وانا على تواصل مستمر مع قاده الطرفين
الجنرال البرهان والجنرال الحميتي
ومساعديهما امس
على وقف اطلاق النار الانساني ثلاث ساعات
وطبقه بشكل جزئي مع تقليل اعمالي العنفلي
بضع ساعات خلال الليل
اتفقها مره اخرى على وقف اخر لثلاث ساعات
اليوم
من الساعه الرابعه بتوقيتنا لغايه الساعه
السابعه بتوقيتنا
التوقيت هنا الساعه السابعه واربعين دقيقه
مساء
ولكن القتال استانفقد نهايه الوقت
ولا اسمع الا الكثير من الاصوات في الخارج
ولكنها اوقات الصلاه
واتمنى ان
يقل القتال في الليل نحن الطرفين
لوقف اطلاق النار فورا والسماح بوصولي
العمال الانسانيين
كما
طالبنا الا طرفين باحترام
الحاجه الى حمايه المؤسسات الامنيه
والسفارات العمى الانسانيين والمنشات
الطبيه
برنامج الغذاء العالمي مع خزانه
كلها علاقات
بين النيران الطرفين ودمرت
في دارفور خلال 48 ساعه الماضيه
وهذا يجعله من الصعب ان لم يكن مستحيلا
للوكالات الانسانيه لتقديمي المساعدات في
دارفور ومناطق اخرى
كما ان المطارات مغلقه وليس بساحه الدخول
او الخروج وبالتالي لا يمكن ايصال المؤن
وببرنامج الغذاء العالمي اعلن عن مؤقت
لايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى دارفور
العمليات اليوميه
اوقفت الان استطيع ايصالي موظفينا
وانهم طردوا مكاتبهما واخلوا عنها
وفي بعض الاحيان
شديده ربما بجمله واحده حول جهود
الدوليه الامين العام
وانا على اتصال مباشر بجنرال برهان وجنرال
الامن العام ايضا
مع القاده الاقليميه من ضمنها الاخرين
قال هذا الافريقيه ايضا عقد جلسات طارئه
يوم الاحد
ويطالب الا طرفين بوقف النيران والتفاوض
من اجل التواصل اوقف اطلاق النار والعوده
الى
الظروف السلميه
والاطراف الاقليميه
تعرضت التوسط بين طرفين
ونحن نتعاون مع اي جاتوه والاتحاد
الافريقي
والاليه الثلاثيه هنا في الخرطوم وكذلك
على صعيد المقرات وهنالك دول اقليميه اخرى
مجامله الدول العربيه ايضا عرضت
لن تلعب دور الوساطه وهذا مرحب به ولكن
هنالك صعوبات تخص وفي امكانيه الوصول الى
البلاد ولن يكون من السهل ووصولي
الوسطائم الى هنا
والطرفان المتقاتلان
لا يعطلنا انطباع بانهم بالتوصل الى اي
سلام قريبا
وكل واحد يطالب بطرف الاخر
بالاستسلام
وهذا
لا يبدو على انه
يعبر عن اي استعداد
لتقبل
جهود الوساطه
شكرا
الى السودان
ولا احد سيتمكن من الدخول الى السودان
الان
ونحن نتحدث كما تحدثوا الان عبر الوسائط
الرقميه اخر
لا نستطيع التحرك صعب جدا حتى اخراج
الموظفين بعض المناطق خاصه الخرطوم
الذين هم عالقنا في مناطقها الا قتال
الصعب اخراج المنازلهم اتواجد وقسطا
كذلك الا من خلال وقف اطلاق النار
وبالتالي نتمكن عقد اجتماعات
مباشره ولكن هناك جهود منسقه على صعيد
المقرات
من الجانبيه الامم المتحده هنا وكذلك
امانته
والاتحاد الافريقي
طلع الحج
شكرا عليه حاطتك على الحاج من قناه العربي
والحدث
كل هذه الجهود الدوليه والعربيه
والافريقيه من اجل التوسط للتواصل الى
وقفه اطلاق النار واستنى في الحوار بين
الاطراف
ولكننا نستمر بسماع البيانات
الناريه من قبل الطرفين حتى اليوم السيد
يوسف عزت المستشاره السياسي
لقوات الدعم السريع تحدث مع قناه العربيه
وقال وانا اقتبس بان الوقت قد حان للقتال
وليس للمبادرات
كما قال
بانهم بشكل كامل على التلفزيون او مقر
التلفزيوني وراديو في الخرطوم
وكذلك مطار الخرطوم منذ يوم امس وان
الحكومه او الجيش الحكومه
ولا حتى يحاول السيطره عليها
في ظل مثل هذه البيانات واتوقع نجري مقابل
مع البرهان لاحقا اليوم
والمزيد من التصريحات الناريه من جانبه
فقد اسم حمدتي انه متمرد وسوف يحاكم في
المحاكم اذا ما اعتقل او امسك بهم في وجه
مثل هذه البيانات اي امل لدينا من اجل
التوصل
الى حل سياسي لهذه الازمه عبر الحوار
والعوده
الى العمل او العمل الانتقالي الديمقراطيه
هذه التصريحات الناريه
الغرض الاهداف الاعلاميه
وربما لجذب المتابعين
وفي نفس الوقت نعم اعتقد بان هذه البيانات
تعبر عن ما قلت فهي لا
تعبر
عن الطرفين وخصمين
يدعوان الى توسطنا التوصلي الى حل مساله
سياسيه انا شخصيا وزملائي على ارضي هنا
وكذلك من الاتحاد الافريقي نحن لسنا في
طور عمليه التوسط من اجل العوده الى
العمليه السياسيه او التوسط
من اجلياء حل ما اقوم به خلال اليومين
الماضيين هو محاوله
التوصلها الى وقف اطلاق نار لثلاث ساعات
يوميا
واذا ما نجحنا في ذلك
وسنستمر يوم غد بجهودنا من اجل هذا الوقت
الانسان لاطلاق النيران
ونبدا بخطواتنا من هناك وبلا شك هنا لقوات
على الارض
والقوات المدنيه والاطراف السياسيه
والاحزاب السياسيه
والجمعات المسلحه
في اتفاق جيوبا الملك يدعم ذلك وفيما خاصه
الجنرال البرهان وحماتي
فانا اتحدث معها عبر الهاتف
عبر الوساطه الالكترونيه
فقد استجاب بشكل ايجابي لهذا الوقف
الانساني ولكن
هذه ليست نهايه القتال
بل هي فقط ايقاف مؤقت من اجل اغراض
الانسانيه انا كمثل اممي
ومثل الامين العام فهذه هي الاولويه
القصوى الان امل العوده الى العمليه
السياسيه
والى حل دائم فهذا الشيء
نامل ان نلحق ونحن وشركائنا الاقليميين
وكذلك طرف السودانيه صنع حققه لاحقا
كبيره من التعزيزات العسكريه في ضواحيها
الخرطوم في شمال الشرق والجنوب خليكم ايها
المعلومات حول ذلك
كما هنالك تقارير
او التواصل الاجتماعي تعليقات حول مقتل
حميدتي اليوم تقول انك على اتصال
مستمر به وبجنرال
البرهانك تحدثت معه خلال ساعه القيل
الماضيه او انه على الاقل على قيد الحياه
وهل تعرفوا اين مكانه
لم اتحدث معه لانني كنت في مجلس الامن
واجتماعات اخرى خلال ساعات القله الماضيه
ولكنني لم اسمع اي انباء
حول مقتل اي من القاده
من الطرفين اليوم وليست لدي اي معلومات
حول سؤال اذا طرحتيه حول تعزات القوات من
اي من الجانبين
ونحن عميان في وجه كل ذلك نحن جالسون في
منازلنا وتلقى نفس التي تردكم
ونحاول تهدئه الامور هنا في الخرطوم
وفي منطقه اخرى من السودان
هذا ولكن الوضع الحالي المعارك اي طرف حسب
تقييمات المتحده الذي هو المسيطره هو وكل
ما تشهدونه هو الان وما يجري من قبل هذه
الجنرى حل ارتقى اي منهما الى مستوى جرائم
حرب
انا لست مراسله حرب هنا بل انا مسؤول اممي
ولا استطيع ان اقيمه حتى وان رغبتم من هو
المسيطر هنا كما قلت في مقدمه وفي كلماتي
بان الوضع متقلب جدا ولا استطيع ان ارى من
هنا ولا حتى اي واحد من زملائي لا استطيع
ان نتحرك لا نعرف من المسيطر على المطار
على سبيل المثال ولا حتى المشاه العسكريه
اما السؤال حول اي من الاعتداءات ولا شك
بان هنالك اعتداءات هل ارتقت منها الى
جرائم حرب فهذا
القرار ان يعود الى مؤسسات مختلفه مثلا
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ولكنني استطيع
ان اقول بان
هنالك انتهاك لمقر منشات الام المتحده ان
المنظمات الدوليه لم تحصل على الحمايه وان
المدنيين غير محميين ايضا
قلت بانك تتواصل مع قاده الطرفين عبر
الهاتف هل كان هناك تواصل فيما بينهما
واهل كانت هناك علامه الاسبوع الماضي
عن التوصل الى اي شيء
اشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات